um what kind of wife do you want to be
oh off the sorry I did that thing where
you breathe in the mic I think of the
basis of my previous relationships and
from what I've learned
because I've never been married I think
I could provide emotional support moral
support
um
specifics okay so emotional support I
need to know exactly what that is if
you're gonna come to me and tell me you
have a mental disorder or a you know
anything you want to keep dating guys
with mental no but you know
I don't believe in a permanent person
okay okay we're gonna get the same one
but what yeah right right
and I just want someone lovely that
doesn't stress me out okay and if I have
that you just picked the guy with the
mental this one I don't looking they
just find me maybe maybe it says
something about me anyway